swords in one piece have a will of their
own that needs to be tamed by its
wielder which is the key to zoro's next
step to becoming the strongest swordsman
in the world we have to talk about
swords so the power system in one piece
is
weird for lack of a better term the main
thing used to be double fruits that
we've discussed in depth recently and
then haki was introduced as a
counterweight but at the same time also
enhancement to the devil fruit system
that system is luckily starting to make
more and more sense but it sure is a bit
confusing probably on purpose like i'm
58.4
sure it's on purpose point is if you
don't have a devil fruit you can still
become ridiculously strong by being a
powerful hockey user
however you don't ever see anyone
without a devil fruit simply fighting
with their body except sanji he
literally is the only person i could
think of that doesn't use a weapon
though he technically is a human weapon
himself so given the latest developments
in the manga and yes this video will
contain some spoilers for zorro i want
to talk about the third and least
discussed part of the one piece power
system weapons or more precisely swords
hi my name is manu i keep wanting to buy
a katana even though i don't have any
space left in my room and today we're
gonna address the latest reveal around
swords in one piece what it actually
means to create a black blade and why
zorro has now reached the next level as
a swordsman also i know you already get
this but for the few people who seem to
be confused about this i tend to start
my videos with an analysis fully based
on the material and then end it with
some theorizing i just like to think
about what these things could mean and
look like in the future so swords have a
special place in my heart as a one piece
fan many of the most legendary
characters in the story are swordsmen
zorro brook mihawk the samurai of wanos
such as uma or oden whitebeard shanks
rayleigh and even roger himself
now on the surface one might think that
swords are nothing but tools that
pirates use no matter if strong or weak
but since luffy luckily has a man in his
crew that aims to become the strongest
swordsman in the world we do know that
there is much much more to these weapons
than meets the eye after all oda went
through the trouble of introducing a
whole grating system for swords with
countless regular greatswords 49
skillful greatswords 21 great great
swords that's kind of funny to say as
well as 12 supreme greatswords each of
these greats or meto as they're known in
japanese tell us something about the
quality history and power of the blades
mihawk's yodu and whitebeard's mura
komogidi for instance are part of that
exclusive dozen now interestingly enough
there are two philosophies in the one
piece world that at first glance at
least seem to oppose each other on the
one hand we have mihawk who holds the
title of the strongest swordsman in the
world right now and thus undoubtedly is
one of the strongest characters in the
series while training zorro during the
time skip as he teaches him about hockey
mihawk tells us the following about
black blaze
the idea behind this is pretty
straightforward i think it doesn't
matter if you wield a supreme grade
sword or a kitchen knife if you are a
true master of the blade any sword can
become a powerful weapon as zorro nicely
demonstrates in this seat here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the sword is nothing but a tool that
depends on the skill of its wielder
after arriving in wano however i
couldn't help but realize that the
philosophy of the samurai here was quite
the opposite of this swords and their
names hold extreme meaning here and were
talked about almost like human beings
shusui is regarded as much of a national
treasure as city uma himself tengoyama
tells us about the nature of the three
kitesu blades and then we get introduced
to enma odin's old sword that
immediately starts draining zoro's power
[Music]
in that moment it became clear that
certain blades actually harbor certain
abilities enema for instance clearly
takes its user's hockey and channels it
into attacks of amplified power so once
again the border between sword and
swordsmen became a bit more complicated
certain swords have certain powers but
then again what about brook's ice
attacks is that his skill or his sword
or kinemon's fire cutting he taught that
to zorro so seems to be a skill that can
be done with any sort what i'm saying is
just like hockey or devil fruits swords
in one piece are just as complicated so
which one is more important now mr
mihawk's skill or sword i mean you run
around with one of the 12 most infamous
blades in the world but the truth of
course is is that i don't think mihawk
is wrong with what he told zorro mihawk
knows that a good swordsman needs to be
subscribed to my channel for next
generation anime content that and that a
great sword makes a big difference
that's why he decides to use yoru after
acknowledging zorro
mihawk is emphasizing skill over blade
during zoro's training for two reasons i
think first this lesson is about hockey
and coding one sword so it doesn't get
damaged it's about zorro learning to
make any weapon as deadly and effective
as possible but secondly mihog knows
that without reaching enormous
proficiency as a swordsman you can't
even hope to use the benefits of a
special sword such as yoru and right now
zoro is already immensely powerful more
powerful a fighter than the scabbards
who are considered strong even among the
strong people of wano and still he is
barely able to keep enma from sucking
out all his power or doing what he wants
and so it seems that truly special
swords require skill on the highest
level and so for mihawk the priority in
teaching zorro was increasing his own
power instead of unnecessarily telling
him about the benefits of a great sword
oh by the way quick question to my
spanish speaking audience because i've
always wondered mihawk is supposed to be
a spanish inquisitor right like that's
the vibe i get from his looks just
wondering anyways now with zoro's fight
against king and his flashback to his
time at chimozka village a lot of things
have been starting to clear up also i
just need to say how much i love that
flashback in general i can like never
get enough of the story connecting us
back to the beginnings and give us more
context okay so we see zorro's
interaction with an old man at the
village who turns out to be shimotsuki
kozaburo the legendary smith who
illegally left wano and founded the dojo
in the east blue even though zoro didn't
realize it at the time
[Music]
was the one who forged enma for odin and
he teaches us a lot about swords in just
a few panels and so together with zorro
we can start piecing things together
kozaburo teaches us three very important
things about named swords first and this
might be the most important one each
graded blade has its own sort of
personality and power secondly good
swords choose their wielder and wait for
the right person there are no cursed
blades it's just that wielders of strong
swords can't live up to the sword
standards and thirdly a powerful sword
must be tamed and bent to the
swordsman's will that is an awful lot of
information dumb we got there and as a
quick caveat to all of that i want to
say that kozaburo might not be the most
reliable source since his idea that
swords are only meant to kill seems not
very oda-like to me i think you agree
that as gandalf put it a sword's true
purpose should be to keep alive and not
to take one and since we learned that
shimotsuki village was founded by
pirates who knows what kusabudo was up
to or who he was sailing with 50 years
ago rox that being said he is one of the
best if not the best sword smith we have
met in the story who forged both enma
and the wado ichimonji so while i think
that zara will come to a different
conclusion when it comes to a sword's
true purpose he most likely knows what
he's talking about when it comes to
these other things and this has huge
huge implications like nami's mysterious
increase in bra size huge this is beside
the point but does anyone else prefer
her original design anyways the fact
that swords are in some way or form
alive is an incredible reveal not
exactly out of the blue but incredible
nonetheless the idea that objects can
come to life from a close and emotional
bond with a person is not exactly new in
one piece the going marry and it spirit
are the most prominent examples here i
guess
[Music]
and similarly it seems that a truly good
sword that is forged with passion and
care by a skilled craftsman also gets
some sort of spirit breathed into it
okay so this is gonna be partly
speculation but i think it's founded
really well on what we already know
about swords by now the stronger the
sword's will the stronger its power
seems to be but it also means it becomes
harder to control and tame by its
wielder for example while many regular
swordsmen were not able to control the
sonde kitsu zara was already good enough
a swordsman to wield it he felt the
sword's will and passed its test
[Applause]
is on a completely different level which
is why zorro is struggling with it so
much now at this point where i want to
talk about zoro's next step as a
swordsman i'd like to draw an important
distinction between two things given all
the information we have right now i
strongly believe that being able to
control a powerful sword is not the same
as being able to turn a sword into a
black blade zorro comments on how odin
was able to wield emma with ease however
despite fighting the likes of roger and
whitebeard on a regular basis odin never
turned enma into a black blade meanwhile
ryuma and mihawk did the trick to
controlling a powerful quote-unquote
cursed blade as kusaburo says is taming
it and bending it to your will that
immediately reminded me of all the times
that luffy used his hockey to tame wild
beasts
and it's not any hockey he uses it's
congress hockey similarly when zorro
finally surrenders his haki to enma
suddenly his conquest hockey bursts out
enma literally is training zorro to use
congress haki and i think that's what it
really takes to control a sword of this
caliber looking at many of the other
most powerful swordsmen like roger
shanks rayleigh whitebeard odin all of
them had congress hug
and i think for all of these monsters
it's their weapon that is able to bundle
their crazy hockey and make it a lot
more efficient and usable similarly to
how luffy is learning to coat himself in
conqueror's hockey i think zoro will
have to learn that as well kaido for
instance is clearly doing exactly that
when he knocks luffy unconscious with
his thundabagua not because of the
damage but because he overwhelmed
luffy's will
or of course when whitebeard and roger's
blades don't touch and so that i believe
is zoro's next step as well taming enma
and earning its loyalty after that
however the question of course will be
whether zoro will be able to turn his
blades into black blades the answer is
of course yes would be kind of stupid if
he didn't but what exactly does he need
to do to achieve that now my personal
opinion is that a black sword is quite
similar to an awakened devil fruit you
have to fully master the sword and its
individual personality to unlock its
true potential but even more so i think
that zorro has to form a true bond with
his swords they are important to him as
objects yes but he has to get to know
each of their personalities and form a
true relationship with them in order to
do what only true masters are capable of
and speaking of awakening if you want to
learn more about that topic and what
luffy's next step will look like i
recommend you check out that video right
here what are you doing no go go watch
it go go go go no no you have to you
click it here